annalena baerbock trifft no mercy lenski
elf wochen nach kriegsbeginn reiste
heute erstmals ein mitglied der
bundesregierung in die ukraine die
außenministerin hat sich in lucia und
ihn ein bild gemacht von den gräueltaten
des krieges und sicherte zu dass
deutschland weiter hilft militärisch und
finanziell
die ukraine wird bestehen dass hatte
bundeskanzler scholz in seiner
fernsehansprache zum 8 mai betont und
mit spannung hatte man auf das
weltkriegs gedenken zum 9 mai in
russland
geschichtete mobil machen oder
kriegserklärung durch putin die blieb
aber aus es gab trotzdem weitere
russische angriffe kein frieden in sicht
was hilft der ukraine unser thema in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
guten abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf meine gäste vorstellen
ich begrüße marie agnes strack
zimmermann von der fdp die vorsitzende
des verteidigungsausschusses die reist
er als einer der ersten abgeordneten in
die ukraine und fordert schon länger
dass deutschland schwere waffen liefert
und herzlich willkommen sie windeln von
den linken sie ist fraktionssprecherin
für internationale beziehungen und
abrüstung sie warnt vor
waffenlieferungen und setzt auf
verhandlungen und herzlich willkommen
roman gontscharenko er ist redakteur der
deutschen welle mit dem schwerpunkt
osteuropa stammt selbst aus der ukraine
und holte vor kurzem von seiner
familienmitglieder aus der ukraine nach
bonn und herzlich willkommen johannes
warwick er als professor für
internationale beziehungen und
europäische politik an der
martin-luther-universität in
halle-wittenberg und schon vor dem
überfall auf die ukraine haben sie sich
in einem appell für eine andere
russlandpolitik eingesetzt
frau strack zimmermann nun haben wir
heute den besuch gesehen von
außenminister annalena baerbock in der
ukraine jetzt ist ein regierungsmitglied
eingereist es gab so viele verwirrungen
ob herr scholz reisen soll ob der
bundespräsident reisen soll sind sie
jetzt erleichtert ist diese verwirrung
jetzt endlich damit beendet ja ich
glaube das war jetzt suboptimal ist sind
ja sehr viele staatsoberhaupt da kann
man sagen dorthin gereist nun muss
letztendlich jeder für sich natürlich
selber wissen wann ist der richtige
zeitpunkt gekommen ich finde frau
baerbock war ja schon mal da kurz vorher
das ist ein gutes zeichen ist dass sie
da war vor dem krieg also unmittelbar
vorher in der ost ukraine
ja ich glaube dass sie das sehr gut sehr
beherzt gemacht hat und sie war ja nicht
nur in kiew besser gesagt sie war auch
in butter wo eben dieses diese
unvorstellbare tragödie passiert ist
dass zivilisten ermordet worden sind ich
glaube das ist ein gutes zeichen und man
soll die reisediplomatie nicht
überbewerten es ist natürlich wichtig
gesicht zu zeigen aber man muss auch was
mitbringen und ich glaube für die
menschen die gerade im krieg sind die in
den kellern sitzen nicht rauskommen ist
neben dem besucher neben wichtig dass
auch entsprechend hilfe dem land hilfe
zu bekommen darüber sprechen gleich
welche hilfe denn am besten dann auch
wirkt frau dagdelen finden sie es
richtig dass die außenministerin heute
nach kiew und auch nach innen und butter
gereist ist
außenministerin wer wollte natürlich
auch ein zeichen setzen gegen die
verbrechen die in butter begangen worden
sind ich bin das richtig dass man auf
verbrechen
hinweis dass man eine aufklärung fordert
und natürlich auch die bestrafung der
täter
ich finde nur man sollte da auch nicht
mit zweierlei maß messen wir haben ganz
eindeutig kriegsverbrechen begangen
worden sind durch die usa in afghanistan
und im iran zum beispiel und julian
assange als ein journalist habe
daraufhin gewesen und wird in
großbritannien eingekerkert schon seit
jahren seiner freiheit beraubt ich finde
da würde ich mir auch wünschen wenn die
außenminister die bundesregierung auch
dort nicht schweigen sondern sagen nicht
diejenigen die kriegsverbrechen begehen
enthüllen und veröffentlichen wieder
getan sondern diejenigen die sie
begangen haben wo das ich zu beantworten
haben und die zweite frage ist natürlich
mein reisten es findet ja sehr viele
reisediplomatie nach kiel statt die
frage ist nur bringt das den kindern die
lösung die sie brauchen nämlich ein
waffenstillstand dass das leid und die
zerstörung beendet wird zumindest
gestoppt wird und da habe ich meine
zweifel wenn ich mir die sprache von
außenministerin werbung anschauen und
ich kriege unsäglich ich muss das jetzt
an der stelle direkt mal sagen dass die
linke jedes mal versucht ein eine
kriegsgeschichte mit der anderen in
irgendeiner weise im kontext zu setzen
wenn dir das wirklich unsäglich wir
sollten jetzt mal hier über die ukraine
sprechen und nicht immer diese spiele
dass man mal schnell den scheinwerfer
woandershin link also diese sendung
beschäftigt sich mit der
sie sollten sich schämen dass sie sich
nicht wie die freiheit eines
journalisten einsetzen der seit über
zehn jahren mit seiner freiheit frau
bradl ein hoch bei der us amerikanischen
kriegs veröffentlicht man darf nicht
daran diese in dieser sendung sprechen
wir über die ukraine und die frage ist
was der ukraine hilfe nicht würde sie
bitten bei diesem thema zu bleiben sonst
können wir hier miteinander keine
diskussion führen und ich auch eine
reise in ein
ich möchte sie jetzt bin zur oralen
bitte sind ich leite diese diskussion
und ich würde sie bitten sich danach
jetzt aufzurichten und es so eine eine
gesprächskultur hier in dieser runde zu
haben dass jeder hier auch zu wort
kommen kann und dann auch nicht frau
stratmann direkt anzugreifen
ich würde gerne jetzt weiter sprechen
über die ukraine die frage war und die
frage an sie richten herr gontscharenko
inwieweit der einen besuch von frau
außen mit der außenministerin wie
wichtig der war heute gerade nach diesen
ganzen verwicklungen zwischen dem der
frage ob scholz ob steinmeier reisen
sollen und wie mit welche erwartungen
man da auf deutschland und auf die
hilfen aus deutschland schaut
ich glaube dieser besuch heute von
annalena baerbock war sehr wichtig sie
war ja die erste bundesministerin sei
dem kriegsausbruch also seit zwei
monaten
und sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass auch andere
ministerpräsidenten und vertreter
anderer länder schon längst da waren
schon seit anfang april haben wir eine
ganze reihe von besuchen gesehen auch
einigen besuchen
manche wird der britische
ministerpräsident boris johnson waren
schon da spazieren aktiv und haben für
sehr viel stimmung gesorgt
großbritannien hilft der ukraine sehr
und ich finde deutschland könnte sich
auch zeigen deutschland liefert jetzt
inzwischen auch schwere waffen und es
ist wichtig dass diese verstimmungen die
es gab zwischen kiew und berlin wegen
der reise von bundeskanzler scholz und
der abgesagten reise von präsident
steinmeier dass diese verstimmungen
endlich beigelegt werden und deshalb ist
es gut dass jetzt zunächst die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas da war
jetzt annalena baerbock das nimmt ein
bisschen druck aus der ganzen sache für
beide seiten und das heißt sowohl tiere
als auch berlin profitieren jetzt von
dieser reise von an einer berbalk sie
waren sie das letzte mal in der ukraine
war das war kurz vor dem krieg sehr
willkommen und ich glaube das ist sehr
wichtig dass sie auch klare botschaften
aus spricht jetzt und diese botschaften
lauten die ukraine braucht noch mehr
unterstützung notfalls auch mit weiteren
schweren waffen und noch wichtiger jetzt
in den kommenden tagen und wochen ist
für kiew eine eu beitrittsperspektive
darüber darüber sprechen wir auch noch
da hat sie sich also machen wir gleich
wird gerne herrn verwickeln die
diskussion mit einigen er war weg es gab
viele verwirrungen zwischen deutschland
und der ukraine bundes der bundeskanzler
hat in seiner ansprache ja klar gesagt
putin wird den krieg nicht gewinnen die
ukraine muss bestehen
was macht ihn da so sicher ihrer meinung
nach dem warum ich will noch einen satz
zu der reise von frau bär borg sagen
wurde noch nicht erwähnt die deutsche
botschaft ist wieder eröffnet worden ein
wichtiges signal dass wir der ukraine
beistehen und wieder sozusagen
diplomatie fähig sind und wir müssen
solidarisch mit der ukraine sein dass es
gar keine frage wir können über
sozusagen die die ziele glaube ich nicht
streiten die ziele sind wir müssen die
souveränität der ukraine waren und
möglichst auch die territoriale
integrität die frage ist nur mit welchen
mitteln wir das erreichen und da können
wir glaube ich heftig streiten und dann
bin ich der meinung dass wir nicht nur
unseren fokus auf waffenlieferungen und
militärische lösung setzen sollten das
gehört auch zur politischen realität das
kann man nicht ignorieren ja aber wir
müssen mehr energie auf diplomatische
lösung setzen und das ist die aufgabe
der außenministerin haben sie denn den
eindruck es geht im moment nur dazu
stark um waffenlieferungen und man das
andere wird vergessen den eindruck habe
ich weiß natürlich nicht was hinter den
kulissen passiert ich hoffe dass mehr
passiert als man
mitbekommt und ich gehöre nicht zu denen
die
waffenlieferungen mit einem hohen
moralischen ross verdammen und ich habe
auch keine briefe unterzeichnet aber ich
frage mich was mit waffenlieferungen
erreichen wollen wir sollten den krieg
vom ende her denken und wenn wir ihn vom
ende her denken dann glaube ich nicht
dass wir mit immer mehr sachsen
schneller und zu einer besseren
politischen lösung kommen als wenn wir
jetzt schon mit diplomatischer energie
eine lösung vor vor denken und die
ukraine auch für eine solche lösung
möglicherweise gewinnen weil die
interessen zwischen der ukraine und sind
nicht immer deckungsgleich
wenn man vom ende er denkt können sie
damit gegen das er wie gesagt wir müssen
das eben beides bedenken sie fordern ja
sehr klar haben sich ja dafür
ausgesprochen dass wir mehr waffen
liefern das macht die bundesregierung ja
auch jetzt werden panzerhaubitzen
geliefert gemeinsam mit den niederlanden
also wie wichtig ist es dass man jetzt
diese waffen liefert ihrer meinung nach
also in der tat muss man ist von hinten
denken ich glaube nur dass wir ein
unterschiedliches von hinten
interpretieren denn gestern hat ja
wladimir putin noch mal in moskau
anlässlich des 9 mai ist das ende des
zweiten weltkriegs ja noch mal betont
der krieg würde lange gehen er stimmt
also auch seine bevölkerung darauf ein
sein ziel ist unverändert die ukraine zu
komplett von der landkarte zu streichen
als teil eines selbstständigen landes
wenn man also dieses ende nimmt dann
bleibt uns gar nichts anderes übrig mehr
als dieser gewalt entgegenzutreten das
heißt nie dass man nicht versucht
miteinander zu sprechen um das an der
stelle auch zu sagen ich glaube aber und
so wie wir das auch einschätzen gibt es
überhaupt keine gesprächsebene mehr
schon im vorfeld des krieges als dort ja
sehr viele minister waren und auch der
bundeskanzler mit putin sich
auszutauschen an diesen skurrilen langen
tisch der sehr viel aus gesagt hat war
er putin ii an den worten zu messen
sondern an den taten und die taten sind
eben dass es eine invasion ist ein
überfall ist ist ein krieg der eben auch
wer eine geburtsklinik
bombardiert wir frauen vergewaltigen
lässt kinder verschleppt damit sie in
russland aufwachsen sich ihrer heimat
also nicht mehr erinnern wenn ich also
dieses ende nehme fehlt mir momentan
jede vorstellung mit putin sich noch an
einen tisch zu setzen und insofern
glaube ich das ist die traurige wahrheit
dass er militärisch eine antwort
bekommen muss weil ihnen natürlich auch
durch die sanktionen die sehr harten
sanktionen natürlich auf dauer auch das
geld fehlt um einen krieg zu finanzieren
das muss man wissen es kostet neben der
tragödien in der lage diesen krieg
militärisch beenden und die ukraine muss
diesen krieg dann gewinnen militär ja
ich wage den vergleich das war 1940
chamber lienig aufgefordert hätte hitler
militärisch zu begegnen mit gesprächen
hätte man weder ein adolf hitler noch
andere kriminelle zur vernunft gebracht
das ist ja das schreckliche das wir ja
mit putin kein haben der unsere
spielregeln völkerrecht akzeptiert wo
man dann all along sagt wir müssen uns
jetzt mal an einem tisch sitzen das ist
es eben dass er eben nicht fragen warum
sind sie gegen waffenlieferungen
nun ich bin dagegen weil erstens
widerspreche ich jede these dass man
gegen eine nokia macht hier einen sieg
reden erringen kann irgendwas hat ja
kürzlich darauf hingewiesen
richtigerweise das in einem
atomzeitalter gegen eine atommacht
militärisch an krieg nicht zu gewinnen
ist es sei denn man möchte gefahr laufen
dass man hier eine automatik
letztendlich mit eskaliert einen dritten
weltkrieg
herbeiführt oder bereit ist dazu
sozusagen dieses risiko auszunehmen und
dann wäre am ende völlig egal wer schuld
ist an diesem krieg sondern weil wir
alle darunter leiden werden also
insofern halte ich das für falsch das
zweite ist dass man die verhungern keine
krieg beenden die antwort auf einen
krieg noch frieden sein und nicht noch
mehr waffen noch mehr schwere waffen von
dem noch nicht man weiß wo sie
eigentlich genau eingesetzt werden wo
sie vielleicht auch am ende landen das
wissen wir bei kleinen und leichten
waffen schon seit jahren und sagen denn
deshalb auch dass man sie verbieten muss
dass man da absolut
reduzieren sollte und ich möchte hier
auch darauf hinweisen man muss ja auch
um so was ist in die strategie also wir
wollen alle ein ziel erreichen nämlich
dass das leid und die not der
bevölkerung in der ukraine aus wird wie
erreiche ich dieses ziel erreiche ich
das dadurch dass noch mehr waffen und
dadurch noch mehr tod der störung elend
dort herrscht und dass es mehr opfer
letztendlich folgen werden oder erreiche
ich dass ich mich konzentriere auf eine
fahndung die frage ist ja wir verhandeln
die frage
wer noch verhandeln will
und die ukraine die oak was sagen sie
dann aber die
sehr gute gute versuche in istanbul
beispielsweise unter dem ermittlung der
türkei gab es diese verhandlungen und es
war schon ziemlich hoch sein das hat
erstmals ein dokument worauf man sich
geeinigt hat die ukraine hatte selbst
schon gesagt dass sie bereit sind mit
der neutralität dann mit dem don was mit
der krim also es war schon ziemlich
aber letztendlich
dazu geführt dass der britische
premierminister johnson als hingereist
und gesagt hat nein wir wollen bis zum
letzten ukraine hier kämpfen und ich
finde das wirklich zynisch hier bis zum
aber die region zu kämpfen wollen von
london aus finde ich zynisch ich finde
was wir an hilfe leisten können für die
ukraine ist alles zu tun alles zu tun
und ich sehe eben nicht dass alles
vergebens wochen im parlament nur
fokussiert auf die waffenlieferungen
welche schweren machen noch gegen ok
werden
herr farbig ist aber wenn man die
ukraine will ja mehr waffen die ukraine
sagt genau wir brauchen diese waffen
muss man demnach geben es ist richtig
ich habe deutlich gemacht in meiner
ersten ausführung dass ich solidarisch
mit der ukraine bin und ich den konflikt
ganz klar so wahrnehmen dass russland
gewissermaßen da absolut zu verurteilen
ist das ist überhaupt keine frage aber
wir haben keine deckungsgleichen
interessen mit der ukraine das muss auch
mal ausgesprochen werden unser ziel
jedenfalls mein ziel ist dass wir eine
auseinandersetzung eine militärische
auseinandersetzung mit russland
verhindern und vermeiden das ist dass
die oberste priorität und die zweite
priorität ist der ukraine beizustehen
und wir werden möglicherweise nicht
alles gleichzeitig haben können und ewe
wie hoch ist die gefahr dass wir selber
kriegspartei das ist werden das hinter
damit zusammen wenn vorstands immer man
sagt wir müssen alles dafür tun dass die
ukraine nicht verliert dann ist doch die
frage was ist das alles enden wir dann
doch irgendwann bei einer
flugverbotszone oder schritte davor zum
beispiel ausbildung von ukrainischen
soldaten die ersten sind jetzt wohl in
deutschland und werden ausgebildet am
gepard ist das schon ein schritt in
sozusagen die kriegsbeteiligung und wo
endet dass das heißt mir scheint das
nicht durchdacht zu sein mit welchen
mitteln wir jetzt die ukraine
unterstützen ich glaube am ende wird
tatsächlich keine
militärische lösung erreichbar seien
jedenfalls keine die russland von dem
weg abhält sonst müssen wir einen krieg
gegen russland führen das wollen wir
nicht deswegen brauchen wir kompromisse
wird geschenkt dazu fragen
also welche möglichkeit sieht denn die
ukraine überhaupt noch in verhandlungen
in einer art
also zu einem frieden zu kommen zu einem
waffenstillstand weil das was wir aus
der ukraine hören ist ja immer der
wunsch nach mehr waffen
das stimmt nicht ganz ich würde gerne
darauf eingehen was ja war bekam anfang
gesagt hat
also ich finde es auch richtig nicht nur
über waffen zu sprechen sondern auch für
die über die diplomatischen lösungen und
natürlich laufen solche gespräche und
eben ich muss da widersprechen der
darstellung dass dazu wenig diplomatie
läuft nämlich wir erinnern uns es fahren
fast täglich oder alle paar tage klingen
wir nachrichten wo westliche politiker
entweder mit dem russischen präsident
telefonierte oder sich mit dem treffen
erst vor wenigen tagen war der
un-generalsekretär görisch in moskau und
in kiew
davor war der österreichische
bundeskanzler in moskau hat mit
präsident putin gesprochen und war sehr
pessimistisch danach vor wenigen tagen
hat der französische präsident marco mit
wladimir putin telefoniert und wir haben
auch danach nichts optimistisches von
ihm gehört und davor gab es andere
versuche also diese
diplomatische linie die läuft ja nur
leider ist das mein eindruck ist most of
moscow überhaupt nicht bereit da
irgendwelche kompromisse einzugehen
im gegenteil wir hören aus moskau die
betonung wir wollen auf jeden fall
unsere ziele durchsetzen und diese ziele
lauten also die kernforderungen von
russland sind die ukraine soll die krim
als teil russlands anerkennen und die
sogenannten volksrepublik in
internetkonten hans chr als unabhängige
staaten das was russland gemacht hat und
natürlich sagt nein das können wir nicht
machen wir sind bereit diese sachen
auszuklammern und später über die zu
verhandeln aber wir können nicht hier
kompromisse eingehen das wäre selbstmord
für ihre regierung und es gibt überhaupt
keine unterstützung für diese
forderungen von von moskau aber
wenn da jetzt erst noch mal richtig
läuft ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
das das russische ziel ist wenn es dass
das russische ziel wäre nur in
anführungsstrichen den don bass und die
krim zu behalten dann glaube ich und ich
bin hier nicht derjenige der am grünen
tisch über die ukraine entscheidet aber
dann glaube ich das wäre eine
diplomatische lösung im sinne des
einfrieren dieses konfliktes wir werden
den damit nicht lösen natürlich und
russland um das auch noch mal zu sagen
wird den konflikt dauerhaft verlieren
weil es mit diesem fall nicht mehr kommt
aber im auf und lernt nicht gereicht
richtig dann muss man auch eindämmung
machen das ist gar keine frage das
passiert ja aber auch wir sind sehr viel
stärker wir sehen doch jetzt wie
schlecht das russische militär
aufgestellt ist aber russland kann
eskalieren und zuletzt zuletzt auch
nuklear und das ist jetzt nicht dass wir
da wie das kaninchen vor der schlange
uns alles gefallen müssen weil der
andere nuklearwaffen hat das nicht aber
ein staat der bereit ist für seine
vitalen interessen alles zu tun und das
ist in der ukraine für russland der fall
der ist auch am ende bereit tatsächlich
zu eskalieren und da können wir nicht
mitgehen ob wir das ist überhaupt nicht
vorstellbar dass sie gern das ist das
dilemma frau strack zimmermann
wo sagt würde nur ganz kurz ein kurzes
beispiel dass das für mich zeigt wie
bereit beziehungsweise nicht bereit
russland zu verhandlungen und
kompromisse lässt während des besuches
des neuen generalsekretärs in kiew herrn
görisch wurde kiew mit russischen
raketen beschossen und menschen starben
dabei ich glaube das ist eine ganz klare
botschaft
[Musik]
ich glaube dass dieser krieg natürlich
mit waffen geführt wird wie kriege so
sind in seiner bestialität sondern auch
ein krieg der kommunikation ist und
diese frage atom was könnte passieren
ist ja das narrativ war sehr putin auch
immer schuld weil er genau weiß was das
bei uns auslöst die letzten tage haben
in der öffentlichkeit wurde auf diesen
neunten mal geschaut und ich glaube dass
es wirklich menschen gab die an dem
wochenende sagten die genießen ist jedes
nicht was morgen am 9 mai ist am 9 mai
war das was jeden neunter moskau ist man
gedenkt das ende des weltkrieges
und hat seine paraden die war diesmal
etwas bescheidener war ja vieles des
militärischen materials nicht da waren
wir auch noch schlechtes wetter grund
die luft war finde ich fliegen dann hat
er hat putin das gemacht er hat kein
szenario er hat auch nicht die die große
was auch erwartet wurde die große
mobilmachung sonne hat sein menschen
dort erklärt dass das ein
vaterländischer krieg ist jetzt werden
wir wieder von den nazis angegriffen was
für ein zynismus dass man über die
ukraine von den nazis spricht in der
ukraine leben viele viele menschen
jüdischen glaubens
holocaust natürlich klar dass da
brauchen die punkte reden wo wir
schneiden können jetzt auch für
sinnvoller das ist doch partie
bestreiten ja schon darüber und noch
nicht dass sie sagten dass sie sagen ich
streite mich gerne dass sie sagen dieses
atomare gefahr ich sehe diese die
atomare gefahr nicht ich glaube es ist
bewusst immer wieder ins spiel gebracht
und weil wir gerade von atomarer gefahr
sprechen vor jahren war ukraine usa
russland ukraine die drittstärkste
nuklearmacht der erde und hat dann die
nuklearen waffen abgegeben an russland
mit der maßgabe ihr passt simpel aus
rück auf uns aus nichts davon ist hat
stattgefunden
jetzt ist dieses land überfallen worden
und nochmal dieses land die ukraine muss
mit westlicher hilfe nicht boots on the
ground keine soldaten dort deswegen wird
es auch keine flugverbotszone geben aber
warum hören mich nur wo ist die grenze
dass das kann ich ihnen sagen die wird
es deswegen nicht geben weil es geht ja
nicht nur darum flugzeuge zu verhindern
in den luftraum einzudringen sondern wir
eine flugverbotszone will lassen sie
mich das auch den zwischen auch der
berliner müsste auch just ausstellungen
auf russischem boden beschießen von dort
aus nämlich sozusagen die raketen auch
dann unsere flugzeuge treffen ist man
seit wochen jetzt ist aber die frage
jetzt bilden die ukrainische soldaten
aus an diesen panzer damit sie diese
panzerhaubitzen bedienen können ist das
schon sind wir damit wolke reportern ein
völkerrechtlich ist es ein eindeutig die
ukraine ist angegriffen worden darf sich
verteidigen völkerrechtlich ist ein
eindeutig dass die nachbarn mit material
helfen dürfen so das ist ein eindeutig
und wir halten uns im gegensatz zu
wladimir putin als völkerrecht was nicht
geht ist unmittelbar in den krieg
einzusteigen also soldaten dorthin zu
schicken beziehungsweise mit gerät
sozusagen auf russisches material zu
schießen ich finde wir sollten da schon
sauber bleiben und noch mal auch das
narrativ was immer wieder von moskau
kommen wird hier vervielfältigt und
verdreifacht und vervierfacht und ich
glaube wir sollten an der stelle sehr
konkret seien sehr vorsichtig sehr ernst
die situation ist sehr sehr ernst aber
uns nicht sozusagen zum verbalen
handlanger wladimir putins machen frau
darin wie sehr sehen sie denn
deutschland auch in einer ja auch in
einer historischen verantwortung
gegenüber der ukraine nach der besatzung
sind zweiten weltkrieg nur an all das
leid was dort passiert ist wo sie sagen
da haben wir als deutsche nochmal eine
besondere historische verantwortung
damit dieses land so bestehen kann und
dass wir diese verantwortung dann
wahrnehmen auch in dem wir eben
militärische hilfe leisten
also natürlich
ist eine der zentralen lehren aus dem
deutschen faschismus mit millionen
dutzende millionen opfern und darunter
höchsten blutzoll haben die sowjet
bürgerinnen und bürger bezahlt 27
millionen menschen der sowjetunion sind
gestorben sind auch volles deutschland
faschismus aller nationalitäten und die
lehre ist natürlich einen friedlichen
ausgleich mit allen nachfolgestaaten der
sowjetunion und mit allen meinen ich
tatsächlich auch ahnen wir können die
geografin ich ändern wir müssen auch
eindrücklichen ausgleich mit russland
haben russland ist unser nachbar wird
unser nachbar sein aber wie kann denn
auch aber heimkommt gerät natürlich kann
das dann aussehen an frauen
und deshalb müssen wir wegkommen davon
erstens die gefahr herunter zu reden so
zu tun als wenn es diese nukleare
gefahren ich gebe wir haben am zweiten
weltkrieg diese gefahren dieser art und
weise nicht gehabt aber wir haben
eine atomzeitalter und wie ich sagte
viel und machen darauf aufmerksam dass
man jetzt die diesen zeitalter nicht
mehr im herkömmlichen sinne militärisch
kriege gewonnen werden können
am ende verlieren wir alle und deshalb
finde ich das nicht besonders eine
wartungs wolle politik die gefahr
herunter zu reden sondern ich finde wir
sollten dieses recht indem wir unsere
runde sie sagen bis angriff herunter
nein um gottes willen ich habe von
anfang an und da unterscheiden wir uns
tatsächlich dass ich da keinen
unterschied mache beim völkerrecht wenn
das völkerrecht verletzt wird so urteilt
ich das klipp und klar und das ist ein
völkerrechtswidriger angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine und das wird
auch von uns verurteilt aber wir machen
da keine doppelte maßstäbe für und
anders auch wenn westliche länder das
völkerrecht brechen und das haben sie zu
genügen bitter was ich aber nochmal
ansprechen möchte ist hier diese gefahr
muss ernst genommen werden und das
zweite ist die gefahr der eigenen
kriegsbeteiligung jetzt gibt es
unterschiedliche meinung der
wissenschaftliche dienst des deutschen
bundestages sagt dass bei der ausbildung
von ukrainischen soldaten an den
schweren waffen die man dorthin liefert
man diese grenze verletzt und
völkerrechtlich dann tatsächlich partei
wird bei dieser krieg bei diesem krieg
also sich beteiligt an diesem krieg man
kann anderer meinung sein aber der
wissenschaftliche dienst des deutschen
bundestages ist keine schülern zeigt
aber es sollten schon ersten mannschaft
aber diese hier eine solche untersuchung
macht um das zweite ist aber auch
komplett sie werden nicht darüber
entscheiden frau strack zimmermann wird
nicht darüber entscheidung ich werde das
leider auch nicht entscheiden können
sondern das problem liegt darin dass
wenn die entscheidung gefallen ist ob
wir kriegspartei sind oder nicht das
wird dann im kreml sein das wird ein
präsident putin seien ja der russische
präsident der die eskalation dominanz
hier inne hat und das ist die gefahr die
ich hier eben sehe und ich sehe auch
weil hier nur in dieser militärischen
logik auch diskutiert wurde ja gerade
wieder gesagt wir müssen militärisch
gewinnen wenn man militärisch gewinnen
möchte heißt das nichts anderes als dass
man nur auf diesen krieg selbst und ich
möchte raus aus dieser politik ist also
sowie glaub ich will euch jetzt glaubt
angeordneten genau möchte eine lösung
haben die frage seid möchte ich dass man
jetzt hier tatsächlich mehr initiativen
ergreifen um diese verhandlungen die ist
ja schon in istanbul gegeben hat
wir wissen dass die ausgegangen dass er
mehr weiß als wir im bundestag uns wird
nicht unterrichtet welche die batterie
diplomatischen initiativen die
bundesregierung tatsächlich hier
ergreift mir kriegen davon nichts mit ok
wissen sie da mehr frau
strack-zimmermann wo sowohl gibt's
punkte wo sie sagen da haben sie eine
hoffnung auf diplomatische lösung also
was wladimir putin betrifft ganz auf ihn
gewünscht habe ich keine hoffnung und
die gespräche in der türkei haben eben
zu gar nichts geführt das ist ja das ist
ja jetzt eine geschichte da kam ein
gespräch zusammen weil sie lynskey darum
gebeten hat wenn es in einer phase wo er
sich durchaus vorstellen können dass man
einen gewissen kommt also eine gewisse
region einfriert zu übrigens
ausschließlich sache der ukraine wir
haben da überhaupt keine schnitte drin
auf was die ukraine sich letztendlich
bei allem möglichen frieden einlässt
weil es deren territorium ist und nicht
das unsrige aber es war eben so dass die
hand eben nicht gereicht wurde sie
lynskey wollte sich mit putin treffen
das war nicht der fall und insofern zu
glauben dass wladimir putin sich mit
zielinski ab ein tisch sitzt um einen
frieden auszuhandeln
das ist einfach naiv weil das nicht sein
ziel und wenn wladimir putin eine pause
macht also einen berühmten konflikt
einfriert von dem ich gar nichts hat es
schon schlimm genug dass wir auf die auf
die aktion der krim nicht reagiert haben
wenn man also diese diese dieses
einfrieren mal ausklammert war die mir
putin will die ukraine vom aus der
landkarte verschwinden sehen und die
millionen von flüchtlingen über fünf
millionen ist jetzt die frau damit wenn
man wegkommen von der diskussion um die
waffen da sind die position jetzt für
mich klar geworden hat ja annalena
baerbock heute ein etwas anderes auch
noch mal betonen nämlich die frage der
zukunft der ukraine in der eu als teil
als mitglied der europäischen union habe
da mal kurz rein
die ukraine ist ein fester teil europas
ich wünschte mir dass wir auf einen
beitrittswunsch eine starke überzeugende
antwort finden auch wenn es auf dem weg
zur eu vollmitgliedschaft keine
abkürzung geben kann weil etwas nicht
noch einmal passieren kann sind falsche
versprechungen aber ich betone hier ganz
konkret
vollmitgliedschaft
vollmitgliedschaft hat hier deutlich
gesagt der gontscharenko wie wichtig ist
dass wir wie ist diese botschaft
angekommen der ukraine
das ist enorm wichtig besonders von dem
hintergründe einem jüngsten äußerungen
des französischen präsidenten mag das
gestern hat er gesagt er hat einen
vorschlag gemacht dass man vielleicht
eine art also keine vollständige
mitgliedschaft sondern eine neue
initiative gestartet für länder wie die
ukraine die dann noch näher an die eu
angeführt werden ohne einer
vollmitgliedschaft so habe ich seinen
vorschlag verstanden und das ist sehr
wichtig dass die frau berbalk da ganz
andere töne angeschlagen hat jetzt in
kiew und das ist genau das was die
ukraine auch anstrebt aus meiner sicht
ist diese eu perspektive für die ukraine
nicht weniger wichtig als
waffenlieferungen oder sanktionen gegen
russland denn das gibt den menschen das
gefühl wir streben hier in die eu schon
seit über 20 jahren und endlich haben
wir bewiesen und gezeigt dass wir bereit
sind zu sterben um zu dieser
europäischen familie zu gehören und ich
glaube es ist auch absolut legitim jetzt
im sommer der ukraine eine
beitrittsperspektive beziehungsweise
kandidatenstatus zugeben natürlich
erwartet gebe da keine abkürzungen nicht
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass keith
realistisch die lage einschätzt und
davon ausgeht dass es jahre dauern wird
aber man wir müssen diesen weg gehen und
das wäre auf jeden fall aus meiner sicht
wie gesagt besser als jetzt darüber zu
streifen wie viele schwere waffen wie
viele wanderungen der welche panzer die
wir beliefern dürfen ich finde das ist
auch sehr wichtig diese waffen lief
nummer 1 ein kurzer satz nur dazu es ist
wichtig wenn es darum geht der ukraine
zu helfen sind aus meiner sicht drei
sachen extrem wichtig waffen zu liefern
dass der westen das tut auch deutschland
sehr gut weiter so und dann harte
sanktionen gegen russland das bedeutet
auch schneller öl- und gas-embargo
hätten nur das wenn man nicht schwerere
waffen liefern möchte wäre ist das
eigentlich die stärkste waffe die
deutschland und die europäische union
haben und dann diese eu
beitrittsperspektive ich glaube mehr
kann man für die ukraine momentan nicht
unter
perspektive eben genau auf alle die
diskussion um die nato die nato beitritt
der ukraine dem man ja dann nicht
gemacht hat aus angst auch vor einer
eskalation also welche gefahren wäre
denn auch durch einen beitritt also
kandidatenstatus mit eingezogen also
zunächst mal finde ich es richtig dass
frau berbalk heute das realistisch
beschrieben hat und keine falschen
erwartungen geweckt hat ich glaube es
ist ein groß style symbolpolitik diese
frage der eu-mitgliedschaft ein land wie
die ukraine wo doch noch nicht mal klar
wie der krieg ausgeht das kann man als
fernziel beschreiben und man kann
normativ sagen die gehören zur
europäischen familie gar keine frage
aber nicht alles was zur europäischen
familie gehört muss auch schnell in die
europäische union wir haben eine
kriterien gestützte erweiterung bisher
gehabt und wenn wir erweiterung
ausschließlich unter geostrategischen
gesichtspunkten nehmen dann müssen wir
auch morgen den balkan aufnehmen
übermorgen
marokko und algerien und so weiter dann
haben wir eine eu xxl die überhaupt
keine bindende wirkung mehr hat und kein
medien ein makro hat recht in der frage
finde wir sollten uns gedanken darüber
machen welche anderen institutionellen
möglichkeiten es gibt er hat
vorgeschlagen und ich finde diese idee
hat charme eine neue europäische
organisation zu gründen in der dann auch
die ukraine moldawien georgien
möglicherweise eines tages mitmachen
könne das in der eu zweiter klasse genau
das ja das ist natürlich ein böses
fremming aber das wäre etwas anderes und
so könnte die ukraine es empfinden das
wird so sein da sind wir werden aber den
punkt unsere interessen sind nicht
deckungsgleich mit den ukrainischen
interessen wenn vom strack zimmermann
sagt sie sind identisch das ist völlig
weltfremd so läuft internationale
politik nicht wir haben eigene
interessen
wir sind freund der ukraine gar keine
frage und wir wollen hier helfen aber
wir haben nicht identische interessen
das zeigt sich in der frage auch sehr
deutlich da muss ich ihnen widersprechen
sie wollen sich mit wir streiten das den
fehdehandschuh nehme ich aber natürlich
haben wir dahingehend dieselben
interessen dass wir gemeinsam mit der
ukraine
unsere werte anstreben freiheit in
frieden achtung der menschenrechte und
das ist ja genau das was platini putin
an der ukraine befürchtet dass gerade in
den letzten jahrzehnten wo die jungen
menschen sich dem westen zugewandt haben
dass die ukraine eines tages wenn sie
sich dem westen zugewandt hat ein
anderes bildungs ein anderes
lebensniveau hat und das land auch
andere staaten der russischen
förderation sagen denen geht es so viel
besser moment war was machen sie anders
als wir das ist das gespenst des premier
putin freiheit in frieden demokratie und
menschenrechte und das verbindet uns mit
der ukraine das ist in den staaten grund
unterschiedliche interessen gibt wir
wissen auch dass die ukraine vor
kriegsausbruch ein vehementes problem
hatte mit korruption das muss man auch
gar nicht beschönigen aber die
eigentliche zielrichtung die verbindet
uns mit der ukraine und das ist das was
die ukraine jetzt auch von uns erwarten
kann dass wir sie da unterstützen auf
diesem weg geben in die europäische
union frau darin was halten sie davon
was sie von diesem fall stürzen auf das
und ich würde gern kurz vor oder anderen
dazu hören und dann
mit der bitte um etwas kürzere antwort
weil wir sicher wie viel zeit haben
bitten fordern was halten sie davon von
dieser arbeit verrichten perspektive
ja ich bin ich dass hier wieder ein
schonvermögen bewegt werden und
versprechen gemacht werden schon wie
damals mit der nato mitgliedschaft wenn
man sich die ukraine anschaut die
ukraine kann nicht anders weise die
kopenhagener kriterien erfüllen im ganz
zu schweigen von der
territorialkonflikte die die ukraine hat
und die eu dazu zu sagen liegt ins boot
holen würde uns mal zieht man mit dem
territorium commons liegt das stand ja
auch sonnenstrahlen in einer ausstellung
auf die insgesamt die eu würde sich
überheben bei einer solchen bayern
solchen manöver ich finde statt
illusorische pflichten historische
beitrittsperspektiven um realistische
beitrittsperspektive
nils auf zu machen brauchen wir konkrete
friedensvorschläge bei einem land was
tagtäglich angegriffen wird von russland
dass dies konkret und absurd und nicht
irgendetwas wohne illusion gespielt aber
da machst du dir nicht erfüllen werden
kann aber die müssten ja dann von
russland diese friedensvorschläge
müssten ja dann von russland kommen es
wäre ja an putin wir haben jetzt das
sagen
ich finde dass es das ist kein argument
man darf nicht müde werden hier gibt
nomadisch initiativ zu werden um diesen
krieg zu beenden und einen
waffenstillstand zu erreichen
und ich möchte es auch noch einmal sagen
man kann jetzt natürlich viele versuche
unternehmen irgendwelchen attraktive
deswegen mehr angegriffen worden ist
oder nicht letztendlich geht es um
geopolitik und es wird nichts anderes
dabei herauskommen als eine lösung zu
finden wo beide seiten ukraine und groß
waren am ende die sich zwar hat eine
einen verhandlungsfrieden dort errichten
eine lösung finden so dass ihr weiter
als mörder hat nicht gesicht zum
auftragen interessen denn wirklich ja
mach es lag auch hier
ich finde es ja nicht gut entschuldigung
frau strack zimmermann
das ist nicht meine politik das ist
wirklich weit weg von einer
emanzipatorischen und linken politik
aber ich muss die internationale politik
in der geopolitik so wie sie ist auch
zur kenntnis nehmen und dann muss man
politik machen und nicht nach mallorca
wo sie ist es nun mal so dass durch sein
handeln zu erkennen anzeigen auf die
polemik
gegen das zur kenntnis nehmen und sagen
okay wie kommen wir zum einen frieden wo
beide seiten mit leben können wenn beide
seiten dazu bereit wären eher
gontscharenko dem habe ich kurz noch
versprochen dass er noch groß dazu sagen
wird und dann feuer farbig und
ich versuche mich kurz zu fassen also
das was präsident marc hom jetzt
vorschlägt und was habe ich wenn ich das
richtig verstehe unterstützt das wäre
die fortsetzung der bisherigen politik
gegenüber ländern wie der ukraine also
östliche partnerschaft mittelmeer
partnerschaft was auch immer er in bezug
auf die ukraine ist es aus meiner sicht
ein fehler denn das setzt voraus dass
die ukraine als eine art pufferzone
zwischen der eu und russland existieren
kann und friedlich aufblühen kann das
ist leider nicht der fall die ukraine
wurde jetzt brutal überfallen von
russland und solange sie nicht erteilt
der westlichen erlernt ist nicht teil
der eu zumindest ist die ukraine in
gefahr und damit auch die juden gefahr
denn die eu muss jetzt sich damit
beschäftigen muss waffen liefern muss
mit flüchtlingsströmen zu tun haben
deshalb wäre aus meiner sicht eine eu
perspektive und ein beitritt der ukraine
zur eu teil der lösung vielleicht sogar
der königsweg die ukraine könnte ja
eu-mitglied werden genauso wie finnland
oder österreich und dann im gegenzug auf
eine nato mitgliedschaft verzichten ich
glaube das ist das was auch russland
akzeptieren könnte momentan nicht aber
vielleicht später ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das russland im moment
akzeptieren will das ist aber auch nicht
die frage die frage ist wie bekommen wir
jetzt einen waffenstillstand hin und ich
bin anders als frau strack-zimmermann
der meinung einfrieren das wäre schon
eine sehr sehr gute maßnahme und
natürlich nicht einführen integrieren im
sinne von verschleppen und dann das
problem morgen mit dreifacher
geschwindigkeit zurück auf den tisch
bekommen dass sich die idee ist
verschleppen das wissen sie nein aber es
ist notwendig da natürlich aber
konflikte die man nicht lösen kann wie
löst man durch einfrieren oder man
kämpft gewissermaßen bis zum ende aber
wir wollen nicht gegen russland kämpfen
das wäre einfach unklug dass auch in
dieser villen genau teams brechen wird
er dieser und
einzugreifen
völkerrechtlich ein land so überwand für
hunderttausende von menschen zu ermorden
ja man sieht nur die klassenräume sind
nur verhindern dass da etwas relativiert
wird das ist ja dass man darum dass man
den menschen die jetzt leiden unter
diesem krieg in der ukraine ist das
nicht die oberste priorität zu sagen
dass diese menschen dass es keine bomben
mehr gibt dass das dass dieses das
ausschaut dann wäre das nicht das was
herr farbig sagt diese an die ss
einfrieren würde das nicht genau den
menschen jetzt helfen die menschen die
dort wir sitzen ja hier im warmen die
menschen die dort unter dem bombardement
leiden wollen dass dieser krieg aufhört
sie wollen in ihrem land bleiben sie
wollen kein land sein was russisch
besetzte ich habe mit jungen frauen
gesprochen die haben gesagt wir sind
geflohen weniger aus angst vor raketen
sondern aus angst vor den besatzern von
den russischen besatzern und wie das
endet haben wir unter anderem in butter
gesehen es gibt noch andere städte wo
das genau so abgelaufen ist und deswegen
wenn mir die menschen dort wenden die
menschen uns sagen dass sie ihr
territorium schützen müssen und jetzt
muss das ausgefochten werden sonst ist
übermorgen moldawien dran überübermorgen
georgien putin wird keine ruhe geben
weil das wies das ist eine genese oder
das ist das gleiche sagen stellt also
erst schreiben genau
in den krieg zu ziehen wir verlängern
mit waffen diesen krieg ein klassischer
stellvertreter trägt das ist so ein
stellvertreter trieb das ist eher das
ist die unterstützung eines volkes was
brutal überrannt und hingerichtet wird
das wäre es dann aber nicht konsequent
dazu sagen dann ein wären wir teil
dieses krieges war das würde dann helft
ihr sind nicht teil dieses krieges wir
unterstützen wir unterstützen übrigens
nicht nur wie alleine sondern 27
insgesamt europäische staaten plus
großbritannien australien neuseeland
japan die vereinigten staaten die
komplette westliche welt rund um den
erdball inzwischen australien könnte ja
sagen wir sind auf der anderen geehrt
google was soll's die komplette
westliche welt weiß worum es jetzt geht
es geht jetzt unsere werte ich sage es
nochmal von freiheit demokratie und
menschenrechte darum geht es und jetzt
müssen wir entscheiden ob wir in der
lage sind gemeinsam mit den partnern die
ukraine diesen weg weiterhin zu
ermöglichen freiheit ist das eine ich
bin sofort dabei und ich würde auch mit
fast allen mitteln für freiheit kämpfen
aber stabilität ist ein konkurrierendes
gut und wir müssen das in einklang
lassen dass ihre ihn entscheiden mich
allein der ukraine sondern auch wir okay
die letzte minute gott sharing die würde
ich gerne ihnen geben weil sie natürlich
noch mal ganz anders auf diesen konflikt
schauen als jemand der von dort kommt
der familie hat gibt es punkte wo sie
sagen ja dass das macht mir nach den
langen wochen trotzdem hoffnung und ich
sehe eine möglichkeit dass dieser krieg
beendet wird
die hoffnung gibt es und diese hoffnung
heißt die ukrainischen menschen ich sehe
wie sie kämpfen wie sie nicht aufgeben
wollen und wie sie unterstützt werden
von ländern aus der ganzen welt wie die
sie haben gesagt haben das gibt nach auf
noch mehr
vielen dank rango frau daher farbig und
frau strack-zimmermann für diese
diskussion sicherlich nicht die letzte
zu diesem schrecklichen thema des
angriffskriegs russlands auf die ukraine
morgen reden wir nämlich auch noch mal
in anderer form darüber da fragen wir
geht es um die botschaft der bilder und
inszenierungen im krieg wäre schön wenn
sie wieder einschalten jetzt geht's erst
mal weiter hier bei phoenix mit phoenix
der tag und anja charlie bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]